does Beyonce throw shade at Kim
Kardashian and her new song with DJ
Khaled plus word backstage with Demi
Lovato and Khaled on their tour also the
Spice Girls omage and Meghan Trainor's
new video
happy Friday TIA
it is my favorite day of the week aka
new music Friday and let's get right
into it because beyonce is spit rhymes
on a new track that's right she and
hubby jay-z along with rapper future are
featured on DJ Khaled's new single top
off and listen carefully because there
may or may not be a subtle disc at Kim
Kardashian ah but the internet top 2 and
I ain't number 2 my teeth my eyes my car
shower I'm a triple threat get up and
nearly come back I don't believe again
top Idol coupang it look like rainy in
the hood howling free meat to D pigeons
me enjoy your Bolton you know cause I
see okay B don't hurt him
let me tell you the Beehive is buzzing
that Beyonce took shots at not just Kim
K but the kardashian-jenner 's what
shade you ask well need I remind you of
Kim's paper magazine cover where she
indeed tried to hashtag break the
Internet then there was Kylie Jenner's
photo of daughter stormy that out stood
Beyonce's twin reveal as the most light
photo on Instagram so is this will be
means by top to but I ain't number two
let me tell you the Internet sure seems
to think so
and that may not be the superstars only
target well I'm my rola it's dead trying
to fight it with the clean they're gonna
have to sign a nondisclosure remember
when Tiffany Haddish told everyone about
how her selfie with Beyonce came to be
and then revealed Beyonce almost beat
someone up for talking to jay-z yeah
Beyonce didn't forget and maybe Tiffany
gave up too much info there in fact the
girls trip star all but confirmed it
herself when she tweeted her reaction to
the song I love Beyonce park everything
she said rang so real to me just know I
will sign the NDA any day for Beyonce
she also added that she will fight for
Beyonce she is a gift from God
well a men to that Kali really knows how
to
pick them though and you know what they
know how to pick him which is why demi
lovato recruited the hit maker for a
joint tour and on the et got an
exclusive invite backstage with them and
opening at Kalani about what fans can
expect from their high-powered shows
[Applause]
this is really exciting for me and I
still can't believe how big my Sage's we
wanted to personalize each song so we
thought what ways could we you know give
the audience and experience and really
take them on a journey
[Music]
this is like a very in control sexy well
we actually only meant for like the
first couple songs to be sexy we wanted
to showcase all aspects of my self as an
artist playing guitar playing piano you
know just thank you and also showing a
sexy side but also being vulnerable and
open with uh with audience
[Music]
girl looks good alright now to a woman
who's slain pretty much everything these
days
miss Meghan Trainor she's busy planning
a wedding but also just dropped some new
music
yesterday she premiered her new video
for no excuses off her upcoming third
album and talked to e t--'s Cal tonight
all about it like a little spice up your
life spice girl vibe happening in this
song thank you for noticing that I mean
yeah I got a little spice life in there
yeah that's why in the music video I had
the two buns cuz I was just like we
gotta go back there and have fun and be
cute with it it's really really friend
you always make a like a great video or
is it grueling to make these like
high-energy videos and it used to be
when I didn't know what I was doing but
now I'm like writing the treatments out
I'm I'm on set days before like we can
fix this wall let's change the color and
now I'm so involved that I look like I
know what I'm doing
and I it's it's really fun to accomplish
at the end of the day like I did that
now if you thought Meghan's video was
colorful
check out BTS breakout j-hope who
released his long-awaited mixtape and
with it this sick visual for daydream
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
but Stalin died
first all-star that [ __ ] down
you're not usin taco night
[Music]
I'm sorry guys that song is already
stuck in my head alright those are your
new music Friday picks for the weekend
and Sunday is the Academy Awards so make
sure you guys are joining us back on
Monday for a live edition of daily daddy
I'm gonna be breaking down the most
talked about moments the fashion the
speech is who got the most drunk I don't
know we'll find out it's the Oscars
anything can happen